♪ ♪
>> Bret: IT’S PENDANT DAYO
FIRST SET THE U.S.
SUPREME COURT, THE FIRST TIME
AUDIO OF THE COURT’S ARGUMENTS
WAS HEARD LIVE BY THE WORLD AND
THE FIRST ARGUMENTS BY
TELEPHONE.
ALL IT TOOK WAS A GLOBAL
PANDEMIC.
CORRESPONDENT DAVID SPUNT SHOWS
US.
>> FOR THE FIRST TIME IN
HISTORY, THE SUPREME COURT’S
PUBLIC CHAMBER EMPTY BUT THE
BUSINESS OF THE HIGH COURT
CONTINUES VIA TELEPHONE.
>> WE WILL HEAR ARGUMENT THIS
MORNING IN CASE 1946,
UNITED STATES PATENT AND
TRADEMARK OFFICE VERSUS
Booking.com.
>> AN INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY CASE
DEBATED REMOTELY WITHOUT ANY OF
THE JUSTICES OR ATTORNEYS ABLE
TO SEE EACH OTHER.
AT TIMES THERE WERE A FEW
TECHNICAL GLITCHES.
>> JUSTICE SOTOMAYOR R.
JUSTICE SOTOMAYOR ARE?
>> I’M SORRY, CHIEF.
>> TODAY’S AUDIO STREAM WAS
STREAMLINED TO THE PUBLIC, ALSO
BREAKING THE LONGTIME TRADITION.
UNLIKE THE USUAL FREE-FOR-ALL
QUESTIONING, THE JUSTICES SPOKE
ONE AT A TIME IN ORDER OF
SENIORITY.
TODAY A RARE MOMENT BY JUSTICE
CLARENCE THOMAS WHO ONCE WENT
FOR A DECADE WITHOUT ASKING A
SINGLE QUESTION DURING AN ORAL
ARGUMENT.
>> JUSTICE THOMAS.
>> YES, COULD BOOKING ACQUIRE AN
800 NUMBER?
1-800-BOOKING FOR EXAMPLE?
>> LIKE MANY ENTITIES THAT I
WILL LEARN TO WORK REMOTELY, ONE
ATTORNEY WHO HAS ARGUED IN FRONT
OF THE COURT 21 TIMES CAN ONLY
IMAGINE THE CHALLENGE.
>> IT’S GOING TO BE A BIT OF A
CHAOTIC SITUATION I WOULD THINK
BECAUSE THE JUSTICES ARE
EXTREMELY ACTIVE.
>> THE COURT OCCASIONALLY ALLOWS
SAME-DAY AUDIO FROM ORAL
ARGUMENT IN HIGH-PROFILE CASES
LIKE BUSH V GORE 20 YEARS AGO
THAT WAS TAPE DELAYED, NOT TRULY
STREAMED LIVE.
>> I ALWAYS THOUGHT THE COURT
WAS DOING ITSELF A DISSERVICE BY
NOT JUST HAVING LIVE VIDEO AND I
THINK THE COURT WOULD BE
PRESSING TO PEOPLE IF THEY COULD
SEE HOW WELL-PREPARED THEY ARE.
>> DON’T EXPECT CAMERAS IN THE
COURTROOM ANYTIME SOON HERE.
THE JUSTICES WILL BE BACK AT HER
TOMORROW ON THE TELEPHONE FOR
THE NEXT WEEK HEARING CASES
ABOUT THE PRESIDENTS FINANCIAL
RECORDS, ALSO THE ELECTORAL
COLLEGE.
THE TERM FOR THE SUPREME COURT
IS EXPECTED TO GO THROUGH THE
END OF NEXT MONTH.